j'ai fait valider ou directeurs de
cabinet des missions pour monsieur
benalla ses missions je veux vous les
citez en toute transparence
la première mission qui était celle de
monsieur alexandre benalla c'était de
m'appuyer dans l'organisation des
déplacements nationaux
je voulais dit donc là je veux tu ouvre
à nouveau une parenthèse m'appuyer ça
veut dire la possibilité pour lui de
faire des missions préparatoires
il en a fait très peu je les ai
quasiment tout fait au niveau national
personnellement eu égard à l'enjeu d'un
déplacement du président de la
république mais il en a fait par
ailleurs il est dans la pratique que
j'ai instauré avec mes équipes de faire
en sorte qu'un de mes watts adjoints
soient présents quelques heures avant
l'arrivée du président de la république
sur un déplacement et donc m'est arrivé
à de très nombreuses reprises conduit
très nombreuses reprises
on a dû organiser qu'elle est une
centaine de déplacements du président de
la république en un an et trois mois en
national à l'international
donc de l'envoyer en avance de phase
pour vérifier que le dispositif mis en
place
ils étaient stabilisés et donc il a fait
ses missions dites entre guillemets de
précurseur je suis désolé c'est d'un
affreux jargon auprès de ma première
mission l'organisation des déplacements
nationaux
je veux fortement vous dire sur ce point
là que monsieur benalla était très
précis dans l'organisation de dans ses
fonctions et que vous savez l'importance
qu'accordent les préfets dans
l'organisation des déplacements du
président de la république et que jamais
je n'ai entendu un préfet de la
république se plaindre de ce qu'a pu
faire monsieur ben alla dans ses
missions préparatoires ou de précurseur
vous en avez d'ailleurs je crois
entendre d'une 2
crois pas qu'ils aient qu'ils aient pu
dire quoi que ce soit sur le vélo je
vous avais deuxième d'autres
circonstances pardon sur cette centaine
de voyages vous avez entendu des préfet
se plaindre au chef de cabinet du
président de la république du
comportement de notre collaborateur du
tout deuxièmement peut-être que j'ai
oublié une négation mais donc je répète
jamais aucun préfet de la république ne
s'est plaint de monsieur benalla dans
l'organisation de ses déplacements mais
j'y reviendrais tout à l'heure parce que
vous m'interrogez certainement sur
l'existence d'autres plaintes il n'y en
a pas eu
deuxièmement deuxièmement deuxièmement
comme les autres chargés de mission de
l'elysée l'organisation des événements
au palais de l'elysée ça va du
rendez-vous à la réception
mobilisant plus de 1200 invités des très
gros événement organisé au palais de
l'elysée troisièmement la coordination
de des deux services la coordination et
c'est comme ça que nous l'avons voulue
sous l'autorité du directeur de cabinet
donc pas la mienne la coordination des
deux services de sécurité de l'elysée
le j'espèrais le commandement militaire
en quoi consistait cette coordination
parce que vous allez me poser la
question très simplement nous avons vu
en arrivant palais de l'elysée que deux
services de sécurité se côtoyer que sur
des sujets très qui n'ont rien à voir
d'ailleurs avec l'exercice de
prérogatives de sécurité il y avait une
meilleure coexistence a organisé entre
notamment sur les questions
je suis désolé ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
sans doute parce que vous attendez mais
en tous les cas sur des choses très
prosaïque tels que le parc automobile
savoir comment faire en sorte par
exemple pour que le parc automobile du
j'espère soit rénové et réhaussée
organiser la coexistence de ces deux
services par rapport aux résidences du
président de la république donc des
choses très très administrative est
absolument pas en lien avec une
immixtion de quelque nature que ce soit
dans le commandement des deux chefs de
service que ce soit le chef du j'espère
où le général commandant militaire du
palais
voilà quel était qu'elles sont quels
étaient les missions d'alexandre ben
alors j'y ajoute également mais nous le
faisions tous également la préparation
de déplacement non officielle du
président de la république mais alors ça
c'est quelque chose qui fait je crois
beaucoup parlé mais le président de la
république
même lorsque son déplacement n'est pas
médiatisé et qu'ils se déplacent ça se
prépare ça se prépare ça se prépare en
termes d'organisation en terme d'accueil
je vais pas rentrer dans des détails
parce que je crois que je sortirai de
mon rôle et du mandat qui m'a été donnée
mais un président par exemple ça ne se
déplace pas seul donc il faut organiser
l'alimentation de personnes qui se
déplacent avec lui
quand il se déplace il faut prévenir les
personnes à l'endroit où ils se
déplacent c'est ça le rôle du chargé de
mission du chef de cabinet dans la
réalisation des déplacements non
publique du président de la république
donc il avait également sur l'arrêt puis
nono répartition en fonction d'un tour
que je décide et de ses missions voilà
donc ses fonctions
elles ont été extrêmement clair depuis
le début cadrée est arrêté par mes soins
sous l'autorité du directeur de cabinet